[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it wouldn't let you eat gum if it's
stated in your stomach for seven years
well it's tiny so it comes out
eventually you don't go back to the
break room Our Daily Show that keeps you
updated on all this nerdy news you need
to know this is our host Jessica Clemens
takeover baby go ahead
God coming up Noir gets left in the past
James Gunn tells us about his day oh no
Wednesday gets a new season you guys
have much much more but today with us
is Angelica Trey oh my gosh first hello
first happy New Year Happy New Year we
can keep saying that right no this is
the last day you can say happy new year
you've all been warned okay I'm gonna
say it until midnight yeah say it as
much as you want don't listen to Brandon
thank you and then I got Tommy back told
happy January 6th everyone okay
you want to leave I will always help me
I didn't say why help me
foreign
my son Nathan was born today it's a
happy day for me happy birthday yes he
was born last year on January 6th we
celebrated for three months after the
Insurrection we should pull up a picture
of him Nathan it's just a fist oh no
there's Nathan
pull up the thirstiest no don't do it
okay
there's Defiance there's a new year and
a new you you guys Super Chat us and
we're gonna give you guys some new user
names for you to use and you better use
these usernames if we do not see that
you haven't changed it I'm coming for
you yeah everyone everyone who sends it
a super chat today we will give you a
new username yes uh that you should use
yeah it'll be great it'll be great like
okay so Christian unpronounceable just
sending a Super Show okay let's give
them an example give them a new username
okay your uh Christian be a big
supporter of the show we really
appreciate it your new username is uh
I'm gonna give you a nice one
um little Mr cheese balls Oh okay little
Mr Cheese you're a little Mr Cheese
uh he's been making a lifestyle out of
the username we gave him don't worry
about it guys just super chat us we got
names on names on names here some of
them are really special
I saw the list no they're not it's not
special of this so yeah new year new
username don't miss outside in the super
chats hey go ahead and hit the like
button if you haven't done that And
subscribe you simps
do that too uh it's Friday here at the
break room we're having a great very
professional day uh and one of the
things we were talking about this week
I don't know if you've seen But Hugh
Jackman he's giving interviews all over
the place and wherever he goes he loves
to talk about Deadpool and Wolverine the
upcoming movie no matter what they're
talking about Hugh Jackman about he's
about he he inserts it into the
conversation uh somehow and while
discussing his uh his illustrious career
The Boy From Oz guys yes uh on an
episode of who's talking to Chris
Wallace
no is it because he doesn't know because
he's so old I don't like who's talking
who's talking I don't like the name of a
show that is a question I don't know
like what would you do I always hated
the name of that show yeah it was a show
for me
Whose Line Is It Anyway what about who's
the boss what about what's happening
what about where in the World is Carmen
San Diego okay I take it back yeah there
you go maybe it's not Chris Wallace like
anyways Hugh Jackman on this wonderful
show so that Deadpool 3 will be a
different Wolverine from what we've seen
before saying quote this is gonna be fun
something I've never done before
it's pretty good that was great it was
authentic I didn't expect it thanks it
made me think I was back home in the
Dilly dance that was a jump scare I'm
sorry I didn't mean to jump scare you
with a Jackman impression uh I hope you
had your Weetabix this morning to do
that you're gonna need a Tim Tam biscuit
to hold you over it's true uh so hit
this quote about him being a wolverine
we've never seen before something he's
as Wolverine has never done before he's
been Wolverine 87 times on film so many
movies for uh Hugh Jackman that's right
um he was actually Wolverine in the PT
Barnum movie briefly right and then they
were like you you come back yeah yeah as
they were going through all the Freaks
and Geeks uh one of them was the
Wolverine and he's like I don't perform
a no circus bub yes the end
um some of you need new usernames I just
realized I hate to be that guy oh John's
already coming out of the booth or
something no you keep going oh okay
now yo my name is
my neck is built for Cuban links okay
and you got to protect your neck at all
times protect your neck all right so
Hugh Jackman saying this like there's a
whole different Wolverine things you've
never seen before I had us wondering
what things we could see Wolverine doing
in this new movie like Wolverine's done
a lot of things yeah over the years he's
had his powers he's had his powers taken
away he's time traveled he's had his
little claws cut off he had a little
bone claws he's got through time he's he
was in World War II he was there for the
the nuke going off most of this is a
lumberjack it was a lumberjack he was in
several other Wars he had a brother he
did porn Canadian porn which is just two
men hugging yeah yeah he he met striker
he ran around in his underwear with the
helmet on he had it hanging out with
kids he dropped an F-bomb oh yeah he
stabbed the guy he stabbed another guy
he smoked a lot of cigars he smoked a
lot of cigars cut a shotgun yeah bought
himself bought his daughter's son all
those things yeah sure yeah all those
things he's already done so what other
new things could he do okay okay now
Wolverine's been in the comments for a
while and as we know when you have a
common character for a while they write
some weird [ __ ] yeah they write some
weird stuff I did a little Deep dive on
Wolverine okay he's had some weird
powers over the air some of these come
back every now and then like he's got
obviously like heightened senses right a
very strong sense of smell I think he's
used that before in the movies he's like
smelled stiff things out and smell when
people there but he also has like a
strong sense of touch
the ladies know that he does he's got a
strong sense of time
he can also he can communicate with
animals which I found to be the most
fascinating thing hasn't done this in a
movie yet right because apparently from
my understanding a wolverine The
Wolverine uh he's been out in the
wilderness before like living with
animals living with packs of wolves
learning how to communicate them but his
mutant power right is really the like
healing Factor yeah the Regeneration
right and apparently when the adamantium
was introduced to his skeleton it paused
his his uh his uh his mutations because
as we know some mutants they keep
mutating over the years the mutations
get stronger sometimes they go through
like a secondary mutation which enhances
their powers apparently if the
adamantium was never introduced
Wolverine would just become like an
animal man like an animal hybrid man
with his bone Club animal yeah a Manimal
he'd get even Furrier than he is now and
just be like full animal almost like the
Beast right
I think he would like just stop aging
completely yeah just he would eventually
just be like this Immortal animal being
an animal talking to animals yeah so he
could Doctor Doolittle on this new movie
you don't want to see a chipmunk and be
like
do you think he'd be nice like what yeah
do the best that was really good that's
kind of bad too I guess
we could talk to you R2D2 yeah
[Music]
uh he also has night vision which makes
sense that's like the animal thing right
yeah yeah well like a well does a wolf
have night vision I think they can see
well at night okay I'm gonna give them
that yeah they run around at night yeah
right they run around they gotta look at
something yeah
this is a good one apparently at one
point in the comics they gave him this
power then they took it away because the
fans didn't like it apparently you could
have hot claws okay meaning he could
like take his his healing factor and
kind of focus it on his claws and focus
the energy and heat them up like little
hot knives do you think he had hot Paws
fun hot claws fun there's no claws
buns man what you were doing I got you I
got you yeah uh but when he's using the
hot claws I guess he doesn't heal as
fast he gives and takes okay I guess the
fans didn't like the hot claws they took
it away I don't like the hot claws
either it's a hat on a hand the thing is
with the adamantium it's it can cut
through so many things and everything
yeah so I feel like they they sort of I
guess I guess it's kind of cool like a
lightsaber you know when you cut off an
arm and it automatically cauterizes it
and let's do that yeah one species they
had Direct con because they later were
like oh he shouldn't have bled in the
bar in A New Hope oh yeah wasn't there a
point though where he got his claws in
something really hot and then he used
them it was just the power yeah oh that
does sound familiar if you're familiar
with that scene in a movie Colin yeah
that would be a cool effect right if he
like ran them under hot water for a
little bit yeah just when you're making
ice cream at home John put my cell phone
in the chat uh and they can call me yeah
docs docs or the Unspeakable laser beam
ions could just heat them up oh yeah
I would like to see that in the movie
you want hot Claws and like Deadpool
didn't make fun of it yeah yeah but then
I think Deadpool should have the lasers
in the first movie now there's also been
we know they love to take things from
the comics and make good references here
so those are some of the powers they
could come out with out of nowhere some
fun little powers from there's also been
some weird moments in the comics that I
found that I think could be fun to be
replicated okay the first one I think is
the most likely okay at one point The
Punisher and Wolverine got into a little
fisticuffs little fighty action and
Punisher being Punisher pull out a gun a
little shotgun he shot Wolverine in the
face and blue is hit the skin off his
face so he's just had the skeleton this
the metal skull face in the eyes look at
this it looks so silly it looks like a
silly boy
and it did it didn't grow back like
right away I don't know for a while he
has this and then he also shot
Wolverine in the balls okay he blew his
balls off it was like it'll grow back so
my prediction for what's going to happen
is that what you call blue balls that
that's a
adios do balls um
it's kind of like a fun thing because
he's like yeah that'll grow back don't
cry about it I didn't pull it but then I
later found the hood also shot him in
the genitals oh wow at some point
because it's mean but it's also not that
mean because they grow back yeah
Wolverine are very quippy way says uh
it's basically like thanks I hope it
grows back bigger oh oh wow question
question here for the doctors on the
panel yeah yeah uh if Wolverine fathers
a child then has his balls blown off he
animates his balls and fathers another
child are those two children related or
are these new balls is this like the
wrench question yes the philosophical
one this is my ship of thesis
it's
the balls but it's the same DNA but they
came from the same they come from the
same genetic map that grew the first
pair yeah so I think they would be the
same but technically they're not the
exact same
difference
yeah yeah well only the same content
okay uh well to get back to this picture
but there was another point in the
comics this now this was a what if yeah
so take it how you will okay uh but this
could still happen Okay Wolverine uh
will the X-Men get in a fight with like
Dracula and the other vampire actually
that some of the some of the X-Men get
killed or turn into vampires Wolverine
is like screw this and goes to fight
Dracula kills Dracula but then becomes a
vampire himself the healing Factor gets
rid of the vampirism but basically he's
still like so he becomes the lord of the
vampire because he was like oh I killed
Dracula so now I'm the lord of the
vampire so he gets a little bit of his
powers but he's not like bloodthirsty
and he can walk during the day but then
he's like I'm gonna go kill everyone
else now so he goes to fight like doctor
strange and all those people
which I think would be fun yeah because
that's how we get Jubilee
um
never mind I'm good that's how we get to
is a vampire because she was the only
actual mutant to really lose her powers
during m-day and that's the only one
that they kept and then they made her a
vampire give her her plasmoids backpack
her plasmoids back but also
that would be something that he's never
done on film if he became a vampire
that's fun right the lowest balls off
make him a vampire all right do a little
Buffet of it and then finally at the
biggest MacGuffin for any Mutant he gets
the Phoenix Force this happened in a
combat One play against the Phoenix
Force becomes like this weird Samurai it
looks like Chewbacca The Collector and
Doctor Strange yeah yeah so those are
some crazy moments we could see in a
movie but I want to hear from you guys
what do you think could be this like new
thing that we've never seen Wolverine do
before right a whole new thing for Hugh
a whole new thing for me and you me and
you me and you yeah what do you got
Jessica I don't know I was gonna go for
Angelica first oh okay okay we're
throwing to me all right um well I know
Deadpool's you know always breaking the
fourth round right so what if throughout
the film at first like Logan's just not
sure about it they're they don't really
have a good companionship going you know
Deadpool's always ribbing him stuff like
that and then yeah you know I got it I
got it
um slowly low it's a warm up and he
starts to notice as their companionship
grows that Deadpool is breaking the
fourth wall and it's kind of like like
the priest and
he's like what was that what was that
and and then slowly Logan becomes more
self-aware and starts to break the
fourth I like that I love that I like it
too especially with the first couple of
times he's like Sally looking oh he's
like a camera he's like not quite
nailing like right directly into camera
yeah
everybody's trying to do it yeah I like
that other he smokes a clove
Andy Smiles afterwards everyone's Jarred
yeah yeah oh no I like it I'm into this
all right Tommy what would you like to
see so we know that the film is going to
have some time traveling yeah uh
elements to it I think that uh Wolverine
and Deadpool are going to get themselves
in a situation where they are so they
have lost their clothes okay
like an explosion
of the situation yeah like they get in a
good way swimming in the river and
someone stole their clothes yeah they
get in the good old-fashioned strip they
do their clothes don't time travel with
them
so my well then this kind of well okay
then we're gonna have to figure a work
around here for Mike because then I
think Deadpool at this point is the only
one who can control the time travel okay
and he's like I got it and he goes to
get him a new suit and the only suit he
brings back and Wolverine's only option
is those yellow X-Men
so he makes Wolverine put that original
X-Men yellow suit on with the fins and
everything after all the teasing all
these years yeah I mean that would be
pretty good I like that yellow suit
I think you would love that I think I
don't think Logan would I think he would
be like yeah I think he's gonna hate it
at first like when you put like clothes
on a cat you know he's gonna be like oh
he's a cat yeah yeah and then and then
eventually he's gonna be like oh well
like this is yeah
I can stretch and move if it Deadpool
starts to hate it because he loves it
yeah he's like all right take it I was
like no no wait I'm keeping it on yeah
it's not fun anymore nor why okay when
they say down Hugh Jackman giving the
vibe of a cat is it is it is cat energy
where's all my Jack offs at Big Cat
energy
[Music]
get out of here
he's more of a Himalayan he's a Maine
[ __ ] he's a blue Russian
he might look like a man come but he
acts like he's a bobcat he's a Bob I
just went away when you nerds started
naming cat breeds I was a cat what
football team is he is he a Buffalo Bill
all right Jessica what would you like to
see Wolverine too that's never been done
by Hugh Jackman or Wolverine oh wait a
minute just by you mean by well yeah I I
buy a huge jacket Hugh Jackman's done
this well Marine I think they're gonna
break out into a musical hell yeah
uh Deadpool is mad that their song has
not been nominated for a Grammy oh yeah
well he's gonna continue making music
and why not grab music from the literal
Music Man himself yeah wow and Ryan
Reynolds I don't know if you saw
spirited has several songs learn to tap
dance because it broke out and singing
and Hugh Jackman is pissed about it like
one of those interviews he was like
pissed that he's he's worried that uh uh
Ryan Reynolds could win some sort of
award for singing
Hugh Jackman's territory yeah
we don't talk about the second one the
greatest showman we don't talk about
what about Australia Australia was there
a song in Australia
did he have a song in Kate and Leopold
you know I mean his performance was
musical I feel like Prestige should have
had a song in it the prestigious I do
magic I make clones of myself it's magic
trailers killing the birds I keep
killing the birds Christian Bell has a
twin brother
they both sleep with the same woman but
one hater one loves her they can never
tell and the daughter knows who her real
dad is That's The Prestige
prisoners oh boy here's here's my pick
for one Wolverine Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine is gonna do this he's not done
film before I've been praying for this
to happen I've been waiting for it when
Deadpool goes to get Wolverine he's not
going to find him at the X mansion he's
not gonna find him at strikas compound
being turned into Weapon X he's gonna
find him hanging out in Canada with a
little group of people no we know as
Alpha flights that's right Alpha flight
is gonna get brought into Canon for the
X-Men Universe by being like this is
where Wolverine was before he went to
the the house of that Xavier built okay
okay he was hanging out without a fight
I'm talking Sasquatch I'm talking
Polaris baby they're all there being
Canadian Living Life the Canadian way
and that's what I want to see the nicest
way possible do you think out of all the
X-Men stuff that we want Alpha fights
the first I think it's the top thing you
think you think it's top three I think
it goes Alpha flight redoing the Phoenix
at the top of that list I I don't know
Tommy B winning a poll for the first
time in his life oh they want that yeah
wait you put in the pool before yeah
I barely had time to sell out now
normally the only time I win polls is
when it's like an act of torture so it's
true we should torture you for that yeah
um uh but before we towards you we
should give some people some new let's
give some new uh usernames out there and
hey if you're you know watching this
with your eight-year-old kid maybe maybe
mute the volume for the next time oh
Christian unpronounceable did change it
to a little Mr Cheese
[Music]
again uh so I'll start off here uh this
is Jamie Riley right yeah Jamie Riley
your new name is gonna be uh sharks or
drones 69. sharks are drones wow get the
truth out okay oh the Salamander
salamander happy Friday from my pals
your new name is gonna be uh All Dogs Go
To Hell
Wolverine the musical let's hear those
sweet adamantium pipes owning them too I
don't think his pipes are enemies
I'm gonna give you these are all really
good it's really hard to choose one
that's the problem I'm Gonna Give You
spew Hefner I don't like that one
uh this one's for okay next week we got
choco Chocobo Chocobo guy thank you
showing my final fantasy lack of
knowledge
well I I clearly had no idea how to
pronounce it I've only ever read it in
my life oh nice it's like when you heard
Hermione for the first time in a movie
and you were like heard me one you're
only one
so who's Chocobo guy going to be now
they're excited to see you Angelica HRA
Community showing up okay
um well I like this one Edgar Allan ho
they're like thank you but I can't
change my name
we've got Pierce Steel which is kind of
a double on top pretty good you went to
a pierced steel I will uh I'm gonna give
you uh Winston puke
nice uh uh dark rift your new name is
all I dream about all day I dream about
Tex-Mex oh nice all day I dream about
Tex-Mex Jess so we'll do Bogey's World
Boogie's World Boogie's world yeah
boogies World your new name is Justin
limber cake oh
oh nice okay this is me this is perhaps
that nod to uh the greatest showman they
promise nothing we promise you a new
name your new name is
uh dolphin hater oh no oh no there you
go
uh Bernard
like it was terrible yeah Bernard your
new name is all orbs no shaft oh it's a
wizard staff all orbs yeah
okay uh Blink 182 top fan I give him
this one give them uh uh that one oh
you're gonna be Dave Matthews Band The
username yeah
the username included uh blw they said
Jess is a real live superhero give them
a new uh super villain because your name
is now brazzer's Dad
[Laughter]
it's a Daddy loves Brown oh no
I will go off the dome right now and
assume Tommy yeah
that feels like the opposite to like
honor student mom or something I'm proud
of my friends my child is on the
browser's role
said happy Friday Cafe let's give Mr
Feeney a new username miss Mr Feeney
yeah
oh man I love that reference okay so uh
this was the stupid one
okay okay we'll do this one taco booze
day
who came up with these I don't know
I think we fed an AI multiple people but
Max Lee said I love Trey Max let's give
Max Lee maxley your new name is chilly
eilish oh that's awesome
okay yeah Colt or the the stew big
t-shirt uh Brad Van needs a new name
Brad man needs a new name Brad your name
will be Peter panuary sixth
oh no Stephen Stephen starkham needs a
new name
um perfect perfect timing your name
Steven starkum is now oh wait you
already did that one yeah shoot
um I'll give you
Wallace and vomit 69.
oh and finally uh Bucky Barnes ATL needs
a new name let's give Bucky Barnes ATL a
new name
What's it gonna be uh you're gonna be uh
General Genie in a fart hole Yeah
uh as they come in uh and we're gonna do
headlines here in a second but first we
want to remind you to check out my
mobile guys you don't have much time
left before January 15th you can stop
spending so much money on your phone
bill every month uh and get their
unlimited plan for 50 off that's right
you can save a ton but you gotta do this
now because it ends January 15th that's
the cutoff date man mobile is kicking
off the year with their best offer ever
before January 15th by any three month
plan and get three months more free even
on their Unlimited Plan uh by going
online only and eliminating the
traditional cost of retail Ryan Reynolds
and the rest of mint mobile is passing
significant savings onto you all their
plans come with unlimited talking text
plus high speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5G Network you can use
your own phone you can keep your
contacts you can keep your number all
that good stuff switch to red mobile and
get premium wireless service starting at
just 15 bucks a month by any three month
Mobile plan I'm shouting in three months
you'll get three months more free by
going to mintmobile.com break room
that's mintmobile.com break room cut
your wireless bill to 15 months 15 bucks
a month atmobile.com break room hurry
please hurry because this offer ends
January 15th that's when it ends Jessica
hit him with some headlines please I'm
begging you hit me with the graphics
it makes me want to stomp in an
interview with green ramp promoting his
upcoming movie the old way Nicholas Cage
revealed that he spider Noir will not be
returning for Spider-Man
[Applause]
they're not showing anyone else
that makes me sad cage said he had not
been contacted about the reprisal but
expressed his interest in his character
I love Spider-Man Noir too I think
that's a great character Spider-Man's
the coolest superhero and then you
combine that with a cage cage knee
Cagney Cagney and bogar and Edward G
Robinson come on it's a great character
he's going off also it's like it's he's
still Spider-Man Noir it's not like
we're gonna give it to anyone else
[Music]
maybe they're saving them they said
spider Noir along with spider ham and
Penny Parker were absent from the recent
spider-verse trailer causing doubts that
their parents are in the sequel I just I
wonder like with Nick Cage's world if
like his managers or his agents got like
a you got like an email from somebody
that was like we'd love you to come in
and do one one hour recording session to
Spider-Man Noir and they were like we're
not even gonna tell Nick about this no I
haven't even been contacted how would
they not even approach him
check out our YouTube short coming on
our Channel soon hopefully about the new
Redfield trailer oh I think he said Drax
I know I heard directions soon
you guys don't know this but when I get
water out of that Fountain it turns to
Gin oh god
um
give me your eggs
he's been doing this voice all day
Jessica give me your ex a size deception
they've been doing this all day for some
reason Brandon was like on the ground
searching for something doing the voice
and it was very scary
I'm just imagining him on this hand he
was just right there I was like what are
you doing it's like a house cat he might
have seen a shadow that interested yeah
yeah yeah there was a cricket I was
trying to eat it ooh not a game a second
season for Adam's Family spin-off series
Wednesday has officially been announced
by Netflix this morning it's a little
teaser by Netflix but it just doesn't
feel good it's all the season one
footage so they were just like we got a
black a second six yeah like a green
light yeah like we're tired of you guys
keeping keep messaging us also like I
guess essentially it's the same clips
from the first season but the voiceover
is new Jen or yeah yeah so she's coming
back she said I'm tired of you guys
using me as a Netflix or as a tick tock
meme no joke she says that in the video
who did the vampires eat on that show I
think they don't drink actual you know
how they do now I don't know how they do
I don't know
in Twilight they did it in New York you
have to tell us artificial blood you
have to tell us if you're available yes
that he's like no I'm not gonna do the
blue anymore I'm going back to Red yeah
I'm all Juiced up on V they're working
through it they're working an animal
like was it Twilight is it Twilight yeah
they just straight up drink like goats
and chickens and then they played
baseball you know I hate to derail the
headline segment but if that is the
future for vampires I understand those
vampire fundamentalists who are like no
we should be drinking people I'm not
rats and chickens and if that is the
case in the Wednesday Universe why are
they concerned about the murder why is
there a sheriff at all if they drink
that blood is that like is that
cannibalism
I think it's like I mean racist now to
assume that they're bad yeah is that
problematic to assume animal
transmutation
back
Jeff Snyder is reporting that the lead
in the upcoming Damon Lindell law of
Star Wars movie will be a POC who has
successfully gone back and forth between
film and television in recent years but
had hadn't hasn't led a big film yet
Snyder mentioned several potential
actors including Brian Tyree Henry my
baby boy uh but could not confirm you
have a pretty good theory in the meeting
this morning
it was really good theory oh okay I
thought you were dead serious about it
oh no I said Jello white no I'm just
kidding I assumed you were joking a
better man
there's been a lot of reality TV okay I
don't watch reality TV yeah thank you
big fat liar came out in 2003. that's
not 25 years ago now it's 20. could this
in any way be Finn the character Finn
they convince him to come back at this
point or is he done Finn I think he does
give me your eggs back I would love it
to be Brian Tyree Henry I think it'd be
a great role for him could we pay off
can we pay our Finn being a Jedi that
would be cool well and the Rumor was the
or the rumor that's out there right is
that this movie's gonna take place in
the sequel Trilogy verse yes that's
right but not not be any of those
characters but maybe have some
appearances I would assume by like Poe
or family I mean I mean Poe Dameron
makes the most sense because one he
flies around he's still he's still
flying around still doing his job
they're gonna have to come up with a new
name for the Empire and a new name for
the resistance I don't know uh don't
ever show me another TIE fighter ever
again
say Steven Yin Steven Yoon yeah I don't
know I think it'd be amazing Jessica
they should put you in the show I'm good
yeah
I saw how they treated my boy what about
Save a Place
what if he goes from reality to scripted
now if you put him if you put flavor
flavor in a Star Wars movie does do you
have to change his clock to like some
sort of space clock yeah it's got to be
okay
that'd be great before Eric Voss would
be reading into that clock so his clock
always says midnight the numbers are no
they change just like slightly because
the gravity of the props
we just read way too much into it it'd
be me the Penguin series will start
shooting in February according to Colin
Farrell uh the Batman's been off will
shoot for five come on
uh the Batman spin-off will shoot for
five to six months right so we probably
won't see this until 2024 right if
they're starting in February I'll be 60
bucks they get done they get done by
like August September or somewhere in
there yeah there's probably a few months
of posts out in 2023. it's a lot of
production yeah it's a ton of [ __ ]
Productions and I bet there's a lot of
effects that have to be done at the end
yeah yeah do we know there's no concept
of how many episodes or anything it's
gonna be yeah yeah
two episodes one episode's just a car
chase what if they did two episodes but
they were like two hours each or like
three hours each oh just four movies
yeah I could see them trying to get
something like really like intense like
that they're like they might all right
was also really praising the uh makeup
Department yeah for like informing his
character like I guess once he put on
all that stuff like it really helped
bring his like insane penguin character
to like I couldn't tell it was him yeah
all I know is give me give me a show
about the police captain of God no no
get the Freak Out
wait a second
why does that guy have three sets of
legs
do you think that he watches it back and
he's like why did they tell me to do
that that's his voice
you do a great job I'm sorry to make fun
of your boys he's on our flag means
death and he's got a British accent that
is why is it still this High get that
man out of here
what a freak oh God James Gunn revealed
to you writing an unannounced DC series
James Gunn reveals he's writing an
unannounced DC series the DC had tweeted
that he was one-third of the way through
uh writing the show and then look at
that little photo would would the
biggest Flex
for James Gunn taking over at DCU B if
he was writing a Batgirl show oh yeah
okay promise me you're not gonna do it
she's gonna be burnt out I would be if I
did a full movie and then I'm like
they're like hey we want you back for a
series like dude don't make me put on
this dude don't make me waste my
freaking time just for you guys to cut
me again and they're like oh not as
Batgirl if they gave her a different no
you're just gonna play a server yeah we
wanted to give you uh secretary uh the
lead cop and your voice needs to go too
occupied get that freak out of here dude
um I wouldn't mind she's amazing I
wouldn't mind if she played any other DC
character I think they um in a kind of
poopy way uh they he should give her
something the same kind of treatment as
he's given not exactly but you know
Henry Cavill and uh Gal Gadot it's like
yeah give her you guys literally just
cut her off when I wonder you know I
assume he's still pretty involved in
Peacemaker though now that that [ __ ] he
he oversees the first season they're two
in a second season you might feel
comfortable being like uh my writers can
handle this
he literally needs to he should not be
right he's gonna be involved they've
probably already written it or at least
write it don't do both you can't direct
and write it right now you're you're the
long the more you're doing here the less
you're gonna take doing something else
so it's like just give it to someone and
I wonder if this series that he's like a
third of the way through writing if this
was an idea that helped get him the job
we know that like uh from reporting
before that he had pitched a Superman
movie I believe it was uh and back
before he got guard into the Galaxy he
had like pinched on was it Superman
movie or like Batman versus Superman one
of those movies he had like pitched an
idea for he had his own idea for and
that's how he eventually found his way
back to DC uh so yeah I wonder if like
this is an idea it had before and it was
already mostly fleshed out I wonder who
the character uh would be uh producer
John kind of pointing out he's he's now
rumored to be directing whatever this
next Superman movie is gonna be okay I
don't know we imagine he's gotta direct
something well they have a ton of
Superman in in the works right now you
know yeah who is that oh no don't we
have like plans for black Superman
they're so bad it's still on the plane
yeah and then like a Superman uh not
like a prequel but him as
um a team like Super Bowl well that was
the announcement when they canceled the
um the Henry Cavill yeah they said
there's going there was still a blackout
when he's like working yeah you're
Superman year one yeah yeah yeah what
he's in Metropolis is Clark Kent uh yeah
he's like can I look through a woman's
clothes
yeah he's not like full Superman yet
James done a serious movie that's not a
horror film
um
Scooby-Doo monsters unleashed
okay this is pretty serious anybody but
zombies
I think they've been mostly horror and
then like yeah the Scooby-Doo movies and
then it was like here's Guardians of the
Galaxy and everyone was like because I'm
who's this freak get this freak out of
here
ever again we all loved it it's gonna be
the answer what's that
super before
oh I don't know what super is uh rayn
Wilson
was horrible
it was it was scary that hammer scene go
watch it
um yeah those are headlines those are
the headlines baby but yeah I'm excited
we're supposed to get more information
this month about DC's plans we'll see if
it James guns like Ezra who never heard
of this guy he's like what no hello
not to be horrible the way that he will
come for anyone else any journalist and
the way he tweets and then as soon as
you bring up Ezra he's like
that's super weird I know that they said
they have the next 10 years planned out
for DC but some news is coming out this
month do we know an exact date well they
kind of because there was that weird
variety Variety article earlier this
week that had a bunch of claims and then
the next day someone asked James was
like Say It Ain't So James
um
it didn't respond to the article it just
was on responding someone on Twitter
being like no because the article was
like they've only planned three years
and there's no Wonder Woman yeah uh and
Ezra Miller's coming back and blah blah
blah and he was like I don't know about
Ezra uh uh he's like we actually have
like eight to ten years he's like there
will be Wonder Woman in the first three
years or something so we don't know yeah
we don't know what's gonna happen but
they did say we'll hear more this month
yeah so we're hanging on to hope and
then and then we might have that Ezra
return because I know we need the flash
like the flash has to connect well and I
think that movie has got to come out
because it's probably important and
expensive it is expensive and despite
yeah despite Ezra Miller and their
Shenanigans there's a lot of people
involved in that movie that deserve to
have their movie come out hard works we
all hate what to see what happened with
that girl these people work hard and
they they should get their movie out
yeah punish Ezra however you're gonna
punish that person but like let the less
rest of the people have their movie no
you know let momoa's Aquaman come out
yeah
let the poor boy have his fish movie
come on let the man
swimming is genuinely like yeah yeah I'm
shaping my head hopefully they give me
that logo yeah
give a man an Aquaman
feed him for a day teach them teacher
man can be an Aquaman oh man feed him in
2027. now nice let's give some more
nicknames out you wanna get some more
nicknames yeah let's give a few minutes
so with film juice films
oh film juice you know what your new
nickname nicknames the Tallahassee tater
tot oh that's adorable that's adorable I
think they called Ted Bundy the tallest
I gotta go
alliteration
handy Tech sending a Super Chat do you
think he will come back for more movies
in the MCU other than Deadpool 3 I don't
think so I don't think so uh he's gonna
be a Shogun now he was pretty much done
after Logan I think that'll be actually
considering the movies about time travel
I could see them doing a like
introduction of a young Wolverine at the
end of the movie like going so far back
in time Deadpool like goes back and see
the Benjamin Button him no like they
just cast a new actor oh he's like
Brandon where are you baby
why a handy tech for that great question
your new username is going to be the
Tate Wrangler oh important to keep
tracks on what kind of job is that uh GS
not available
[Music]
yeah just default inappropriate uh okay
you'll get Ebenezer splooge Oh no just
in time for the holidays
what day is it
Curtis Spriggs sending in a Super Chat
of all the days for my super chats to
work not even sure how to change my name
well Curtis Briggs you better figure it
out because your new username is gonna
be that was a good one you choose your
own but that was just funny I'm just
saying okay uh well so Jess and I
decided we're gonna go with Neil
fartstrom
first one to skid mark on the Move
that's right
says give me that username baby in space
no one can hear you blame it on the dog
now all right see what's Phoenix wants
that username okay well be careful what
you wish for the puke of Earl oh man
[Music]
sharks are drones 69.
yes thank you and storm needs a new
nickname and storm you will be the
rattlesnake boy yes it's actual game the
rattlesnake boys endless Mike one three
three seven one three three seven is
that Elite speak thing I think it is
endless Mike one three three seven Super
Chat what's their new username gonna be
I like
can you can you spell that out no I like
puke Ellington
um
I want to issue a retraction Brad Van
we're not going to give you that
terrible username Brad I'm Sorry Brad I
apologize I gave him Peter panuary six
we're not going to give you we're going
to give you a better one we'll give you
a better one your new name is uh
[Music]
in the end you just didn't drink enough
to be believable oh no oh oh and finally
Travis miles Senator Super Chat asking
what's my name is that an actual
question or do you want to nickname
Travis Travis are you safe travels I
think Travis this one that's a great one
oh yeah Skittles McGriddle that's right
uh Travis Mouse you are now Skittles
McGriff I can't wait to see who gets
this one that's a cute one I was I was
thinking Tim at some point just Tim your
name is Justin
don't forget to change them uh we've got
one more time before the end of the show
so Senator member for us yeah Tommy has
something to say oh yeah it's time for
mandatory
is the most fabulous segment on all the
internet everyone's looking to see what
these mandatory funsters will do next
yes yes you know this is when I get my
three best best friends together to have
a little fun
before the sun is done and by that I
mean the inevitable burning up of this
Earth
uh before we no longer have a viable
ecosystem yes it's gonna burn up or burn
Bernal I don't know Trey that's a good
question I guess
[Music]
I don't think those grapes are correct
all right anyway needed one more I think
Monday's trailer has us all on high
alert for quantumania of course I should
have written in I'm gonna make some both
predictions about the quantum Mania
trailer because we're getting a new
trailer Monday that's right
no Georgia Bulldogs just kidding go horn
frogs I don't care actually which team I
think the horn the Horned Frogs have
Jesus on there so that's true Texas
Christian and also the Bulldog is not
traveling from Georgia to Sofi Stadium
because he's nine years old and will die
on a plane so guess what
I'll take a horned frog over no dog any
day anyhow back to what were we doing
mandatory all right mandatory fun red
flag green flag you know the rules I'm
gonna say something that might happen in
the trailer on Monday for quantumania
you guys are going to put up a green
flag if you think I'm right or a red
flag if you think I'm wrong okay so
first of all this one's a this one's a
little layup play along in the chat
throw your flags in the chat throw up a
flag throw up an egg
throw up a stag uh do you think modak
will appear motor we're going to see
modem modak is my uncle
we're pretty we're pretty sure he's in
this yeah there's been some like toy
leaks some
merch leaks yeah Funko Pop prediction oh
boy the old Funko Pop predictions now
what do we think Bill Murray's dialogue
will be restored to this trailer Janet
Van Dyne you think will he say more than
just yeah I am your son from the Past
who has aged as my prediction starting
to come true
I just it's just him saying more him
saying more I have more dialogue he
didn't talk at all in the first one yeah
yeah well he talked in an earlier
version yeah yeah
so I don't think I don't think I was
saying even more what's up John
Ned Ryerson uh okay now multiple Kings
on the screen at the same time I'm going
green for this one I'm bullish on Kings
I'm saying bye Kings I hope they do it
but I don't think they're gonna no not
in this not in this one I think it's
gonna happen at some point Kings
there'll be multiple Kings and they're
gonna kiss all right now will we hear
the line
you're an Avenger
have I killed you before and give us the
context for this okay in this context
he's going to be looking at yeah this is
Kang we're gonna go back to Cassie in
the in the uh prisoner cell in the
quantum realm and then ant-man's gonna
be in a fighting stance and then we're
gonna hear that line okay I'm gonna say
no
I'm gonna say no I also think no this
was a line that was in an earlier
Comic-Con footage but then did not
appear I'll say I'll say
I don't know well yeah I like it what's
it gonna be yes yeah exactly do you
think it's gonna be cheeky he's gonna be
a little cheeky little cheeky butt do
you think we'll have
um
references to others
this is their number one move that's
such a Thor move I think no I think this
was all about Ant-Man okay what about
thank you Spider-Man all right is he an
Avenger thank you yeah thank you
Spiderman you got knighted by the First
Avenger not technically the First
Avenger that was Captain America but
Tony Stark gave him the little boom
you're an Avenger kid do we think we're
gonna see uh Cassie using
a satchel I think this might be a Cassie
heavy Trail Cassie yeah yeah I think
we're almost the Cassie cut yeah this is
the Cassie cut okay uh do you think so
yeah we're setting up for a lot of uh
youngins yeah yeah we gotta get those
Young Avengers yeah these units
they're like Italians you know they live
in with their parents till they're 30.
uh that and so like by the time the
Young Avengers come out they will have
simply done they'll still be the young
Italian or Young Avengers in their
Italian parent's eyes that's what I'm
saying I hope they call them the young
Italian event yes John knows what I'm
talking about he's Italian
yeah that's right and I also live with
John mom but our situation is a little
different do we think the trailer will
be sent to a funky song Yeah a different
song yeah than than uh not yellow brick
road I think it's going to be set to uh
never mind I think it's gonna What's it
gonna be said too I think it's going to
be set to Closer by Nine Inch I think
it's gonna be set to erotic
[Laughter]
I think there'll be a funky song yeah
new song I think they're oh like a new
song from what we've yeah yellow brick
road but like an oldie like the classic
Marvel Trope yeah I think we'll keep
that sing a song we'll keep it with that
yeah that's they they paid for them and
they're like yeah we're gonna stick with
this it was a cool song it was a cool
song are we gonna get our first glimpse
of William Jackson Harper's character in
this trailer oh I think yes why announce
the casting if you're not gonna show it
in a trailer no
no okay hey no do me a favor I know we
usually burn these episodes put this one
up online afterwards because I want to
come back to my flags and finally last
question okay will we see an actual
other Avenger oh in this trailer oh well
so this would be like Multiverse of
Madness trailer two yeah they're showing
like the a little tease of Professor X
or showing Captain maybe a hammer maybe
a Thor's hammer drops in because they
can Quantum realm it away they can
varying it away I could see them doing
this so maybe even just a just a visual
implying an Avenger
it belonged to the museum Jessica yeah I
think we're gonna see like a window with
like a book by Spiderman a window with a
book by Spiderman folks there you have
it that's red flag those are some tough
predictions I appreciate everybody going
on that Journey with me I know it's
almost time to wrap up for the weekend
everybody knows on Friday afternoon head
back to my Lakefront Chateau and I split
a little firewood so my wife and I can
have a glass of Pinot reached by the
fireplace you do it by hand too yeah
Captain America I ripped the wood in
half my fingernails are destroyed but
no a precious Thorn said in a ten dollar
Superstar okay give them a name what's
the best one we have on here to give uh
Noah precious Thomas
um
I think this one I like that one yeah
oh it is okay we'll give you a choice
Noah yeah I'll give you a choice you can
either be zazlov is right
[Music]
or was right that's love that's Love's
new head of Warner Brothers you could
say zazlab was right or you can be
Harrison corn Harrison corn because get
off my stock
one
those are the new super chats it's a new
year new year folks your new username
guys use them wisely yeah thank you all
right honorable mention to a few of
these I just want to read out uh
freebies for you Daniel day spewis oh
okay Insane Clown fartsy okay uh Pete
David father I like that one the dark
shark Rises oh okay oh Spanky hanky
that's good that's good glass spouses
Cliff saw Guerrera sagu era I saw goo
era Genghis flan school principle 69
underscore 420. the Rhino Rambler the
hamburger did nothing wrong oh he did it
Nasty Nate 99
Doug
and uh Talented Mr equipment those are
good yeah you know go back rewind read
through them give yourself one of those
names if you didn't want to Super Chat
today that's okay uh we hope you enjoyed
your Friday we hope you have a great
weekend it's a new year happy New Year
it's the last day you can say it folks
and thank you for tuning in today uh be
sure to check out uh the channel uh this
weekend obviously and on Monday
Jessica's dropping a hat video about
making the movie number one movie this
weekend we're calling it baby yeah
taking Avatar down fresh and it's been
out for two days a certified fresh
Jessica sauce she loved his chance great
things to say check out her video on
Monday also join us here on Monday the
break room will not be going live at 305
sharp like it always does yes we are
holding we're holding hold we're holding
the line we're Diamond hands
these two Reddit boys are diamond hands
okay we're ready
we're holding
for the Ant-Man and last Quantum Mania
trailer nice to come out during the DCF
national championship game brought to
you by Geico I actually don't know it
was brought to you by I think it's time
I think it's Trojan condos don't know
who it is uh we're gonna hold once that
trailer goes live we go live folks get
your second screens ready because you're
going to want to move that football over
to the second screen put us on the big
screen uh we're gonna be live here on
the break room we're gonna watch the
trailer we're gonna react we're gonna
talk about it we're gonna have a great
time uh Tommy's gonna have a video out
mt's gonna be breaking down the trailer
we're gonna be talking about oh it's
gonna be a hot week next week uh so get
ready for that get your sleep this
weekend Hot Wheels you're gonna need it
uh go builds beat those Patriots yeah
yeah thank you everyone for joining us
thank you Angelica for coming in yeah
having a great time be sure to like the
video subscribe have a great rest of
your Friday have a great week keep it
Gucci please do it uh we'll see you
later roomies have a great weekend like
this guys Oh I thought you're just like
get out of here
[Music]
foreign
[Music]